[Musique]
on idole à la projection
bernard tapie
dernier
ouais je viens
j'aime bien rare tapis
parce que j'aime ça présent j'aime
comment il parle j'écoute ou pas
jeanne devère personnes qu'on en fait à
part mes parents peut-être guitare des
idoles mon papa c'était beau parent
voilà et puis les idoles temps j'ai
peut-être les mines par exemple les
queens
tout ce beau monde où l écorce ya plus
de meneur il ya plus bas y'a plus de
chain et de personnes comme ça qui va
quelqu un corps et un charme fou pour me
garer voilà un charisme ci a peut-être
l'abbé pierre mais teresa tout ça parce
que c'est des gens qui ont fait beaucoup
pour notre société et puis les médecins
de ça mais sinon j'ai pas beaucoup
d'idoles quoi comment pouvons-nous les
idoles les personnes les respectables
aujourd'hui
moi je pense que ce serait une
presqu'île faiblesse de l'avouer en fait
on a peut-être peur de vous dire là
ouais on en fait dit damien van damme
les chances des médias et a pris ce
stade
harrison ford qui nous lisent johnny
depp sont tous américains
physiquement une caisse beaucoup sont
bien bonne joly parce que mastroianni
approche ou ayrton senna c'est des
grandes idoles ils ont quand même donner
quelque chose en formule 1 et puis en
musique mon marché que particulièrement
les épines c1
c'est
idem pas le mot idole comme brassens on
va dire des gens comme ça qu'on dit à la
rigueur un testeur de basket ou la
jordanie c'est tout j'ai vu le chrono je
me balade pas avec un bandana rouge
autour du cou
avec enfin avec ma guitare dont la rue
en train de chanter fois que tout est
fini le temps des idoles où on avait ces
grands modèles on était complètement fou
il fallait dès qu'ils étaient morts
acheter des choses pour eux je pense à
james dean peut-être mais par contre il
ya aussi des écrivains qui compte
beaucoup pour moi c'est du marguerite
yourcenar par exemple comme idole gc
grands écrivains français mais pas mais
j'aime bien d'accord mais je sais
comment il s'appelle il s'appelle match
je suis qu'à hull et le césar de
l'espoir masculin
il s'appelle maggio vite voila fr ses
lecteurs génial et c'est une personne
géniale je l'attends c'est pas une idole
c'est une personne qui ont mis en
réserve parce que là des idées comme
nous et moi je pense qu'on me fasse une
autre journée passée à l'émission
mythique
j'avais vu voilà et je trouve qu'ils
représentent au budget veedol c'est en
plus le concours miss passe pour former
une image c'est pas intéressant pour un
lieu de soin
[Musique]